- HEY, WHAT'S UP?
IT'S ME, ADAM D.
WELCOME TO MY HOUSE PARTY.
CLOMEDY CENTRAL GAVE ME
A BUNCH OF MONEY--
- WHOA, WHOA.
CUT. CUT.
DUDE, YOU'RE DOING, LIKE,
A REALLY WEIRD THING
WITH YOUR TONGUE,
AND YOU SAID, "CLOMEDY."
- WELL, I WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
THAT THIS IS
A MORE SEXUAL SEASON.
WE'RE DOWN HERE
IN THE "BIG EASY."
AND THEN, I SAID "CLOMEDY,"
BECAUSE IT'S, LIKE,
AN IMPROV THING.
- YEAH.
- YOU DON'T KNOW ABOUT COMEDY,
SO--
- ALL RIGHT.
- HEY, ADAM!
WELCOME TO NEW ORLEANS.
WE, UH, GOT YOU
A BAR-WARMING PRESENT.
- OH, YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE.
WHAT IS IT?
IS IT A FLAT-SCREEN TV?
- NO.
IT'S A KING CAKE,
AND, UH, IT'S SUPER
FULL OF WEED.
- SIT THAT DOWN HERE,
YOU FREAKIN' MONSTER.
- YOU TAKE A PIECE, AND ONE
OF THE PIECES HAS A BABY IN IT,
LIKE A PLASTIC BABY.
AND WHOEVER GETS THE BABY
IS KING FOR A DAY.
- EW, I HATE BABIES.
I LOVE WEED, THOUGH.
- [laughs] RIGHT.
- BABIES--BABIES SUCK.
[choking]
I BIT THE BABY!
- TAKE TWO OF THESE
EVERY FOUR HOURS,
AND AVOID ALCOHOL.
- YEP.
AVOID ALCOHOL.
GOT IT.
EXCUSE ME, NOW.
GET--OKAY. THANK YOU!
AND, ACTION.
HEY, WHAT'S UP?
IT'S ME, ADAM D.
WELCOME TO MY HOUSE PARTY.
SEE, LAST YEAR, CLOMEDY CENTRAL
GAVE ME SOME MONEY
TO THROW
A STAND-UP COMEDY SHOW,
AND IT WENT SO WELL THAT THEY
ACTUALLY CUT MY BUDGET IN HALF.
BUT, I TOOK OUT A LOAN
AND BOUGHT A BAR IN NEW ORLEANS,
FREAKING LOUISIANA, BABY.
CUT. OH, MY TOOTH.
IT HURTS SO BAD.
I'M GONNA NEED--I'M GONNA POP
A FEW MORE OF THESE DOGGIES.
JUST A COUPLE MORE, JUST--
HEY, WILL YOU GIVE SOME ABSINTHE
TO WASH IT DOWN?
I CHIPPEDED IT REALLY BAD.
OKAY.
MM. I FEEL BETTER ALREADY.
- AND, WE'RE SCREWED.
- BRRRAHH!
AHH!
[theme music plays]